i-team sources have confirmed
24-year-old destiny jackson who had been
missing since friday morning was found
dead in a desert area south of las vegas
good evening to you thank you for
joining us at five i'm brian loftis i'm
kirsten joyce her death now being
investigated as a homicide sally
jaramillo is live near sloan after
speaking to a family member sally
brian and kirsten the family is still
trying to find answers they want to know
who could do something like this to
destiny just leaving her out here in the
desert
gladys toliafoez destiny's first cousin
the two were like sisters and were on
the stum cut together thursday night
around 11 o'clock a short time later her
family noticed destiny was out and about
based off an instagram post destiny was
supposed to pick up her boyfriend friday
morning but never showed up on sunday
destiny's mother got the call from the
corner to hear the way that my aunt you
know screamed
no mother should have to go through that
destiny
young
super
full of life like she had no fear the
coroner identified destiny via
fingerprints and tonight the family is
looking for answers and justice
out here live a gofundme page has been
set up and if you would like to help the
family make sure you visit our website
8newsnow.com reporting live sally
jaramillo 8 news town